wait a minute do you want to hear out
about our beef yeah well we got beef i'm
told okay so
okay so i'm trying to remember when this
was
yes okay when i had to host i think it
was the bet awards remember i had to
come and do conan a brand
had to got to let's do another take of
that
we mean i had to go do conan o'brien i
had to
they put that [ __ ] on the press i was
like [ __ ]
the [ __ ] like my wife says my wife
says i had to do conan o'brien
[ __ ] about man but i wanted to
do it because i was like kind of
all the white people like him and i was
like
he seems really funny no every time i
sell you you was really funny i was like
i didn't know he was as tall as she was
too and i was like damn this guy's tall
but i don't know who your the producer
was i don't know if you're friends but
he was so [ __ ] weird and
i told him he was a weird [ __ ]
he i don't remember this guy but i just
remember being him making me just not
uncomfortable but you mean the guy that
talks to you before the show i wanted to
beat him up i want to describe him
physically he's like he looked like he
looks like john schaefer
he looked he had he bar head had glasses
i just remember him being nervous i
think he had a condition i don't think
he worked on our show i think he had a
condition
i think he should talk to someone in the
hallway who said no let's go over your
notes for cody yeah he was like and then
he ran down the hallway insisting until
he was insisting on stuff and i was like
no don't talk about that don't talk
about that yeah and then he said well
he's like you have a boyfriend i was
like no it's we were just starting to
talk to each other yeah so i was like no
don't mention that at all because he was
already squeamish about dating me anyway
so he was i was like no don't mention
that and what's the [ __ ] first thing
that you said
you asked about a boyfriend and then i
i'm the type of person that doesn't lie
i really don't lie it's very hard right
so i was like oh we kind of and i think
i said something like oh i think i'm
kind of mad at him or something like
that oh
something i said but i was like in my
head trying to answer you're like what
the [ __ ] why did you [ __ ] ask me that
so the next day this [ __ ] sends
me because after that happened every
news thing picked up no leslie jones is
dating someone this [ __ ] sends
every article that mentions it mentions
him to my phone damn and he was like and
especially sent the clip from your
[ __ ] show and i was like he sends me
the clip but my people was like he's a
[ __ ]
he's a [ __ ] the fact that he sent you
articles that means that [ __ ]
went and looked for these that's bit
[ __ ] so i shouldn't have been with him
anymore i did you a favor you did you
did no i will say [ __ ] off because you
[ __ ] it up no i will say this leslie i
never ever if i knew that someone didn't
want to talk about something i never did
because that would really upset me and
it upsets me to know that that seriously
i don't like that i don't like that
it's okay because like you you said you
did do me a favor yeah well yeah but i
don't like that i don't i don't like
that you were asked something that you
didn't want to be asked because that's
not well i played it off really well i'm
sure you feel bad
don't feel bad the guy's gone
wow and he should have been
maybe because i hang out with him no no
[ __ ] that i bought him a first class
ticket to come out and he didn't show up
oh [ __ ] that guy all right well i did
the right thing then you did he was he
was just i got to figure out who this
producer is because
you're not supposed to do that if
someone says i don't want to talk about
something you're not going to do it
really forceful like he was um i i just
remember thinking this this guy he said
he worked with you for a long ass time
he was the guy he had he i just remember
him glasses and i remember him having uh
a condition because he told me about his
conditioning condition
and he's telling you about his condition
yeah he was saying this wasn't a ghost
no he was saying show
he said he he was cause i was like are
you like
adhd or something or then he was like he
said something that he had and i was
like yeah you know what no i gotta say
what kind of show am i running yeah
where i say hey we need a segment
producer to talk to leslie jones who we
got i'll do it boss
all right uh here's what you gotta do
first of all uh make sure that if she's
uncomfortable with something i know that
it's the first thing out of my mouth
okay got it second of all and this is
important do you have eczema
yeah i have eczema good
make sure you mention it to her
i don't [ __ ] i don't know who i i
just remember thinking this [ __ ] guy
man but he said he had been with the
show forever he was a big fan of mine
i just remember him being short ball
head glasses he looked like john john
schaefer like uh i'm gonna take care of
this
i'm just gonna say some shit's gonna go
down now you're gonna get a finger in a
box on your doorstep
there's gonna be a
hawk's head on your lawn
never mention this guy poor guy oh well
anyway that's so [ __ ] funny
you